[Music]
[Applause]
learning something new every single day
for a week seems fun why not to impress
my son that's the reason why yes the
first thing I wanted to learn was how to
spin a frisbee on my finger it turns out
that's a lot harder than I thought it
was so on day one I tried it out it
didn't go well crispy how hard can it be
it comes with a little bag which I'll
never ever use nice attempt number one
this will be the
Benchmark attempt number
[Music]
two this might be a little harder than I
thought
apparently I was spinning it the wrong
way I was spinning it this way but
you're supposed to spin it towards you
it kind of helps to look at it from the
top like this cuz then you can see how
it spins and get a feel for it and then
you kind of Imagine drawing a circle
with your finger I'm still kind of
learning it but it's definitely first
time I see an improvement I'm just going
to keep practicing this until be is
satisfying it's a lot harder than I
thought all right Mar say's trying how
are you better than me the first
[Music]
time I know why cuz you have the dough
the past the pizza dough fil an
instinct okay maybe
[Music]
not am I boring you
really the reason I wanted wanted to
learn this was because when I was a kid
my dad knew how to do this and I thought
that was the coolest thing ever I even
told all my friends that hey my dad can
spin a frisbee on his finger isn't that
awesome I just thought it was so cool
that Legacy has to live on I had to
learn how to spin a frisbe on my
finger I practiced this a lot and I
actually did this throughout the entire
week for 10 minutes outside cuz BJ liked
being outside and he liked watching me
do it I think it's cuz it's so bright
[Music]
colored that was a good
one the trick is to spin it like here I
started like here so you kind of want to
work your way around here and I think
the problem I had was you sort of
instinctively move your whole arm but
then you it starts wobbling and you lose
balance so you really want to try and
just like focus on keeping traction on
your fingers and the more you do it the
more you sort of get control and you
understand when you can apply Force to
keep it spinning I'm still working it
out but that's what I got so far all
right let's try the pillow
[Music]
today
the final
challenge yeah new skill
online you know I practice stuff that
requires hand condemnation before and
generally what you want is to just
practice a
lot for for many different
days yeah I find it really interesting
just how just sleeping you know just do
a little bit rest and then come back and
then magically you're better how does
that work brain subconscious be like
bruh I would actually love to do this
kind of thing again where I practice
something maybe for 10 minutes and see
what kind of result you can get I just
find that interesting
anyway I bet you're sitting here
thinking I wish I could learn something
too well you can did you know that
Discord recently got hacked and over
700,000 users more got their user data
stolen did you know that did you know
that did you know that well you would
know that if you use nordvpn greatest
VPN ah because nordvpn is so much more
than a VPN it's your best friend it's a
cool Summer's breeze it's a pad in the
back saying good job when you didn't
really do
anything nor VPN monitors the dark web
for you so when a website or an
application gets compromised your user
data is stolen how would you normally
know you would have to constantly look
it up I don't know constant fear and
distress but nor VPN does this for you
so you would know immediately if this
has happened and you know it's time to
change all your passwords with even more
amazing features like threat protection
which makes sure that you don't click on
any oopsies you ever clicked on an
oopsie it's not good use nor VPN so much
more than just a VPN browse the internet
safely the whole internet safely and
securely don't even worry about it bro
if you use the link in the description
nordvpn.com PewDiePie you get the best
deal with a two-year plan huge discount
think think big now multiply it with
huge because you also get four
additional months for free you are
welcome but you have to use my link use
my link and no other link and no other
vpns either use my link trust me I've
been using newvpn for years it's an
amazing service I highly recommend it
and if you want to just check it out
it's 30 days money back guarantee check
it out Bo you got to lose Link in the
description on with the next day day two
I asked Maria my beautiful wife what
should I learn today and she came up
with baking I don't bake sorry I know
how to make Swedish pancakes and Swedish
KCK bread I'd say this is a really tough
challenge out of my comfort zone but I
think in the end it went pretty
[Music]
well what do we have here baking chair
challenge let's see uh dear father I
know you want to impress me but if you
successfully do this mother will also be
impressed
okay this letter contains a clue get
yes your child beard
Donuts cuz it's Donuts around bread
because it's p ball can I open my eyes
oh we are making pomor ball so this is a
really cute kids book in Japan it's
super popular m loves it I love it too
so I get to pick or I get to pick oh my
God yes we got to do the mazui
face it's in Japanese okay this also
became like a Japanese test as well okay
I think we have all the ingredients I
need 40 G of
water 51 this is going to nail
it 39 good enough okay so first we take
a small bowl milk and water and the
yeast I feel like you shouldn't mix
those things that's a little
cursed this feels like a lot of yeast
and then I'm supposed to leave it for 2
minutes and then we grab a big bowl and
we enter all the stuff on the left side
which is the flour and the why
don't use use Des as since we done 200 g
this seems like a lot of flour I feel I
if you weren't here I'd be like this is
wrong in the Big Bowl what was that salt
so this is salt 15 G this is sugar 15
and then finally the salt which is only
G not that much sugar
salt so this is making dough I'm making
dough right now this is flour is
it oh wow they made it so
perf okay I'm supposed to flip it on
itself I have like really gross hands
cuz of the climbing do you want to eat
my bread do you feel stressed out when
you bake no this is you enjoy this B 10
G boom first try nope I'm supposed to
knead the butter in and then it's
supposed to Rice after that
you think you're cool you think you're
cool little
[Music]
guy it looks like a little
baby there you goes goodbye baby and now
the baby will grow 8 hours see you in 8
[Music]
hours 8 hours all right it's technically
day two but it still counts as a one day
activity look at that that's pretty good
next step is to roll it up and cut it
into three pieces we get some
flour what do you think of that hello
little baby there and
there there we go one and two now I'm
supposed to C them out I don't know that
in English 12
CM doing it good
we're doing it good look at that that's
a good
one put it in all right see you in 50
minutes It'll come out like that oh wo
they're so massive they did yeah they
did rice a little bit milk those bad
boys M so now it's cooking time it's
been 30 minutes let's check
out bread it smells really
good it's
SM pretty nice pretty smooth let's cut
the butt
first that's bread my friends I like the
but of the bread it's good it's pretty
good
yeah perfect slice now I'm supposed to
draw this on this with a food pen don't
draw with an actual pen I see what we're
working with here
maybe you know in the future be has a
favorite character which will be
pandorable obviously but little details
so you can draw fun
things I didn't censor it that's it's
really cute let me do the other one as
well
art look at
that and there you have it Pandora brain
very cute
itas not bad bro pretty good recipe I
like it day three I asked you guys for
suggestions on what I should learn that
day and one user came up with shadow
puppets which was perfect I loved it
this was the perfect one- day challenge
cuz it didn't take long to learn and it
was really fun to see the result uh and
I think be absolutely loved it Dan what
do you what do you think of
this any
thoughts no he didn't he's he's still
too young really uh but it's yeah I'm
definitely going to keep uh practicing
these because I thought they were
awesome shadow puppets A+ love the love
learning that I will keep learning that
uh great skill to have to impress kids
and
myself it's a
bunny these are the ones I
learned the first one is really cool I
think you will even like it so you do
like this
weird thing and you're like what the
hell is this right but then the magic
happens and it becomes a
bunny look it's a bunny be hello
little what are you doing today sorry I
don't have time I'm a
bunny I'm a very excited
bunny isn't it cool look it even has a
little eye it's nice to meet you I have
to go
byebye next one be don't be scared this
is
Daddy got
out
oh
be you must e this is too
scary you can do a little nicer version
Oh my God it's
burn I'm supposed to be a dog but I
don't really look like a dog
what do you think
beon what is
this it's a
snail wow it's tough being a snail not
[Music]
impressed it's like the lamest one it
had to be done yay y it's a bird
again it's me The Duck
quack why you're making great noises ah
hello it's
me
m I'm so
bad oh my God it's
B wow I love B he as. gr
as I want to hear your feedback honest
feedback oh wow
thanks
hello I am a moose remember to also
visit your Homeland
Sweden and because we have moose like me
here and it's very good we have really
really good meatballs I think you're
going to like the meatballs be although
we can make meatballs here from Japan as
well um well uh it's been a pleasure to
say hi to you be I forget to
speak does it look
like oh yes I am of
course
day four day four was a bit random
because I wasn't planning to do it but
we were heading out to try out one of
those trampoline parks and I thought
perfect chance for me to finally finally
learn how to do a front flip I can't do
a front flip I never done one I don't
know how to do one but uh I asked the
person that worked there if he could uh
sort of instruct teach me how to do it
and you do it in succession so first you
kind of do a sum salt with uh with your
hands then you do a suult without your
hands uh on a mattress then you try and
do a whole flip without your
hands and then so on and so forth so
it's kind of you take the steps up and
[Music]
yeah
after all that I could do it and it's
cool I can do it all my friends could do
front flips I could never do front flip
now I can do front flip I realized it's
less cool when you're 32 years old but
hey I know how to do a front
flip day five was actually a huge
failure because I was planning to do
something else it already takes up a lot
of time to have a child right now and uh
I only had so much time every single day
to practice one of these things and what
I was planning to do failed completely
so I needed to improvise and therefore I
decided to learn 3D printing except I
already know how to 3D
print we have this little play pen for
bejn and we realize that the it's so
humid in Japan that the ropes were
becoming moldy so I decided I was going
to replace them with something even
cooler than a bunch of stupid geometric
shapes philosophers I PL printed out
Plato Socrates and senaka I was going to
do diogenes but I couldn't find a 3D cat
and I I'm sure as hell not going to
model one myself the result however was
spectacular and I know B is going to
love it so we're going to replace these
but with my 3D prints we got Socrates we
got Playdoh we got
Sena it's going to be beautiful I'm not
going to try and influence you in any
way be like you'll pick the stuff that
you like and you enjoy but also I
apologize about
this it's not a dog toy it's human
toy this is
ridiculous this is just a joke I'm not
going to actually keep these I don't
even know if this type of plastic is
safe for children I just did it and
there's the result there you go
V he loves it but it does look great
they do look very creepy also did a
dumbbell which just pretty cool no as I
was filming it broke what I have this
for you there we go that's my boy right
there I'm not trying to steer my child
in any form of Direction whatever he
will enjoy he will enjoy but
also day six my God learning something
for every single day for this long it
was getting kind of tough I'm not going
to lie but if you want to impress your
child everyone knows the one thing you
brag about when you're a kid is that my
dad can beat up your dad he's way
stronger than your dad or he works at
Nintendo and he can beat up your dad so
I wanted to learn how to do a one arm
push-up my dad can beat up your dad oh
yeah well can your dad do a one arm
push-up cuz my dad can do that I tried
this before and I failed spectacularly
spectacularly
spectacular oh no spectacular
spectacular if I twist my body it's
actually quite easy I can do it my with
my left hand let's try that with the
right I feel like that doesn't count but
it turns out there's a trick to it all
you have to do is separate your legs to
maintain a balance and that's it it's
actually kind of easy I wasn't even sure
if I did it right because it's so easy
but hey I learn how to do one hour
pushup day seven of learning something
new every single day finally the last
day and oh boy that I Sav the hardest
one for last suing sewing suing I'm not
suing you I'm sowing you I'm sewing I
suck at sewing I never sewed I sewed in
second grade I was so bad at this I was
it was genuinely stressing me out and oh
boy did I over complicate it so we just
need to do
this I wanted to make a wizard hat for
be it was so hard I don't know why it
was so hard I felt very dumb and stupid
and I overthought the entire process
hello it's the last day which I'm
actually kind of relieved About Me and
Mar went out to get some fabric and she
show me the ropes we'll see how this
goes I have not
sewn since second grade so I need a
circumference of 10 cm that's a tiny
head so I'm going to try and draw Circle
by using this
method
that's the roundest circle on the planet
right there I'm just making stuff up
here and my did not tell me to do this I
hope the felt Community is not watching
this seems like the kind of community
you don't want to piss off so now I got
to do my third grade math and calculate
the circumference okay that's almost as
big as the felt itself is that so 34.5
maybe
35.5 okay oh it's going to be so cute
that's a very tall hat though now that
I'm looking at it yeah I'll make it tall
it's really scary to do stuff for the
first time I don't have the confidence
and I also don't have the extra fabric
so this has to work this actually
reminds me when I was a kid my mom made
me a strawberry hat a little strawberry
hat and I was so proud of it so a nice
little homage to my mom as well here and
not just my frisbey spinning Dad
hopefully will love it he won't remember
it but hey probably could have drawn
this more towards the
edge I realized I'm very dumb I already
knew this this is where the head's
supposed to be uh this is more what I
was yeah this will work that was a lot
harder than I thought it was but it's
shaping up the way I want it to oh yeah
it's time to sew I feel like I already
messed this up I'm going to have to
improvise a little bit
[Music]
here let's redo that all I needed to
take a break to actually figure this out
my diameter is 136 my radius 68 we have
a circle and I want to make like uh
120° this is the area I need C2 is
427 26 then that means so we just need
to do this divided with
two pi r no that's not what I want to do
pi r i want to calculate so just divide
it by two and Pi that's all I needed to
do okay I shamefully had to sue a bunch
of stuff together because I yeah I just
messed up so bad but now I'm finally in
the sewing properly
face this thing
looks
horrible I'm so done I hate
God it's so bad it's cute
hey yeah hey but in the end Mara came to
save me when I had given up she said she
did 1% out of 99% but I think it was
more like 10 at least 10% I needed
backup that looks so much better now but
honestly as stressful and horrible as it
was seeing be wearing the wizard hat it
made it worth it it was extremely
cute
it's so big I made it a little bigger on
purpose but I didn't think it was that
much bigger that was so much harder than
I thought but we got there in the end
with a Little Help from R it was worth
it just to see him in the Hat to be
honest oh wow it works for the dogs
too no oh my goodness oh but
yeah final challenge completed so there
we go I learned something new every day
for a week but I also bonus learned that
learning new things is very fun and
satisfying not just so you can be that
cool dad who can spin a fris on his
hands you know but it genuinely feels
very satisfying and I do think just
practicing something for a small portion
every single day can actually have
pretty significant results if you just
want to learn the basics obviously so I
challenge you hey learn something new I
wouldn't pick seven things just pick one
thing that's that's a smart thing to do
yeah
if you want a weird and stressful but
genuinely fun and memorable week while
doing something different I recommend it
hope you guys enjoyed this video I had a
lot of fun making it and I see you guys
in the next one
byebye he's strong as hell be that's
going to be at least 20
lbs